henceforth
the men and women of the united states
space force
will be known as guardians
oh no
[Applause]
no it can't be
[Applause]
from our president a man who is actually
in space
right now space farce
[Music]
space is a warfighting domain
comes to the outer reaches of space you
are that strength
if you rise on the wings of the dawn if
you settle on the far
side of the sea even if you go up
to the heavens what the hell that there
his hand will guide you and his right
hand will hold you fast
to defend america and defend our freedom
from space guardians
[Music]
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Laughter]
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
i'd say that poll book is off by over a
hundred thousand
that poll book why don't you look at the
registered voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
did you do you even know the answer to
that no i guess i'm fine
zero zero there's zero yes how many wait
what about what about how what about the
turnout rate
120 percent
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning winning
which to any experienced investigator
prosecutor would suggest that there was
a
a plan from a centralized place
to execute these various acts of voter
fraud
specifically focused on big cities
and specifically focused on as you would
imagine
big cities controlled by david
[Music]
[Music]
david
[Music]
and i'm sure he's listening because he
watches every word and i guarantee you
one thing
he's watching us like he never watched
anybody before
[Music]
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice because
it's going to be called no free speech
red chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the
after all you're gonna love this too
you're gonna make a bomb and i hope they
drop it right on your freaking ass
you but you can't have pork you but you
can't have pork
but you can't have pork just stick that
microphone right up your ass
[Applause]
[Music]
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely triggered
[Music]
uh we we've heard we've heard enough i
think at this point we are waiting for
joe biden's white house press secretary
jenn saki to give a press briefing
she will be joined by bharat ramamurthy
and i expect it's going to be a very
very interesting press
briefing um saying bharat ramamurthi
actually reminds me of that time when
donald trump went to india
and mispronounced let's see trump india
pronunciation these were really really
he they put some really risky names
up on the board for him take a look at
this this is a this is the best
five months ago the united states
welcomed your great
prime minister at a giant football
stadium in texas
and today india welcomes us at the
world's largest cricket stadium right
here
here we go
it gets progressively worse prime
minister modi
underscores the limitless promise of
this great nation
he started out by his father's side
as a chihuahua a t seller
the qriket players heard about you are
not just
the pride of gujarat as the great
religious teacher
swami vivek
[Music]
that's the best one right there that is
the bag
i need one i need that one's more
gujarat
as the great religious teacher swami
vivek
once said
some of the world's greatest cricket
players
from zuchin tendulkar
to virot kohli
anyway this is the one where the entire
place cl started clearing as soon as
donald trump started uh
speaking uh canoon dune i think is the
best
the best one uh okay there we go for
everybody who is demanding that i weigh
in on the big british interview oh wait
a second what's going on here
why do we have why does it say 43
we're not at 43 that's crazy let me see
if i can get that updated
let me get the right numbers for us um
we it's not zero though okay so let's
see jim r subscribed on twitch
general anubis subscribed neymar turf
twisted hawk as well as dreamy girl
palo del green man
okay so that's seven the seven is the
right number can you imagine if i
started with 43
i'd never be able to live it down okay
so for everyone wanting me to weigh in
on the big
um uh royal interview
of course uh megan varkell
and prince william were interviewed by
oprah the other night
um i did weigh in on that on today's
bonus show
okay so i will that i've already
recorded a hot take about it and if
you're a member or a patron
you can listen i know i'm kidding i know
it's meghan markle and prince harry i i
know it's not megan varkell
and prince william um it's on today's
bonus show though is the point
all right so i'm not going to talk about
that today mostly because i don't care
about it
but also because we already recorded a
a whole segment on it for the for the
bonus show okay
um i have a whole bunch of stuff to get
caught up on today
including some new callers we're going
to look at kaylee mcinanny's weaponized
appearances on fox news
i have clips i have memes i have a whole
bunch
of different things going on i do not
have a single unban request to
adjudicate
nobody it seems people agree with being
banned recently because i don't have a
single person who believes they should
be unbanned
thanks to doc elb for gifting 10 subs
via twitch i really appreciate that
um deretend says from us
from us in the uk thank you for not
rehashing it well
yeah i mean i i did it's not that i'm
avoiding the topic i just already
you know how much how much content am i
going to do about the british royal
family anyway
um but thank you to oh wow hold on a
massive dump of subs here uh texas bear
claw
neptune death row boat dk has signed up
via twitch
mecco birdo is number five sumi long is
six
the white link is seven and then docks
ten gifts um that's seventeen
seventeen plus seven seven plus seven is
fourteen four carry the one one plus one
is two
that puts us at twenty four feeling
pretty good about the math so far
feeling better about the math and
trump's pronunciation bae photo says
piers morgan is just a british tucker
carlson
yeah i don't even care about the piers
morgan involvement to be quite to be
quite frank
updates on numbers okay
things are really looking better u.s
cases collapsing down
77 percent we peaked at 255 cases a day
january 11th
we are all the way down to 58 000 that
is a 77 percent decline
um from the standpoint of deaths
deaths still tragic but they are down
from 34 61 a day
all the way down to 1623 that's down
about 50 percent
and then as far as vaccines go
we had a really powerful day on saturday
look at that
2.9 million doses
on saturday 2.9 in one day
and then 2.4 on sunday
only 1.7 yesterday but we are now
averaging 2.17
per day and that is on the way up
that is very very much on the way up um
let's see here post on your subreddit
shows emma from majority poor
majority report wants to switch her
support to your show that sounds funny
let's take a look at this um looks like
we may be making inroads over there at
the uh
at the majority report let's take a look
here put your own spin on what i said
but that's fine
yeah i just added to that right it was i
was backing you up on that i was trying
to be
unified with you in that message well
i'm taking all my money and i'm going
home
that they were not uh unified actually
i'm gonna give it to
another program david pakman potentially
but it's wow
that is a shot across the bow that is
very strong i'm gonna have to text sam
about that
um yikes that's that's i'm shocked to
hear that
that's like if producer pat said he was
gonna go sign up for tyt membership
that's really really aggressive
um thanks for pointing that out nug
wrangler that is that is really
aggressive
uh we're gonna look into that because i
i can't imagine she'll be allowed to
even stay on sam's show
after something like that okay so
vaccine numbers are looking good
um oh i know oh by the way i'm getting a
little bit sick
of the uh the drama about the vaccines
don't work on the variants that appears
to be
very much untrue let me even show you
here
i have an image which may be complicated
for some of our viewers
but this is this is the pfizer vaccine
serum really just absolutely
delicious serum stocked with pfizer
induced antibodies this on the left
is sort of like the main strain b117
let's see if we oh well that's too big
b117 is what we know of as the british
variant
p1 is the brazilian
1351 is the south african and these
d64 you know these two are are
sub-variants of the south african
variant as you can see here very
strong neutralizing uh antibodies
against all of these the most borderline
is the south african variant that is
true that's that's the lowest where
there are
some people because antibody production
is on a bell curve
and so you've got your average and
you'll have some people who dramatically
overproduce
antibodies and some who are on the lower
end it is true
that on the lower end against the
standard south african variant
uh it's it's more borderline but most
people will still develop
certainly immunity to avoid getting very
sick
although you may get you know a cold it
may even be a serious cold in some cases
so far this is looking okay caveats
being
this is in serum and
you know when you test on people rather
than in in serum
lab situations you're going to get
slightly different numbers there's no
no question about that but let's stop
the alarmism
around the vaccines are useless against
the variants in fact the jnj vaccine
was tested later and was tested against
some of the variants and that's why
arguably there's the the hypothesis that
the jnj vaccine isn't even less
effective than pfizer and moderna
it's that it was tested later on
variants and the pfizer and moderna
would have similar uh efficacy
against the uh variants as well okay so
that's that that's where we are on
vaccines
doc elbe says celebrating getting a work
from home job with
telus international i'm grateful right
now congrats doc and appreciate the
support
the juror selection of the floyd chavin
case is happening now
encourage all to listen to some version
of it later oh is that being streamed
because i know they're putting cameras
in the courtroom let's see chauvin
juror selection
uh ah yes they are
let's just see what's happening there
let's see what's happening there we
talked about this on the bonus show as
well
check or look for other evidence that
supports one side or another
yes there there would be there'd be
other people that if it was an incident
they could you know you could have
people that that maybe had witnessed it
or seen it that you would you would also
talk to
and in your um would you do that as a
part of your
analysis or investigation in
resolving this dispute yes okay yes
so
assume there's a situation where two
people are telling you two different
things
and there are no other witnesses and
there are no videos or
time cards or other objective data
available
right maybe this is more applicable to
your kids
how do you resolve that dispute in the
absence of information
well you you know i would listen to the
story
from both individuals all right so jury
selection this brings back memories to
the days of the
um george zimmerman trial a trial we we
watched very closely years and years ago
uh we'll check in on that again maybe
after the uh gensake press
briefing ethan says david do you have
thoughts on the pro act i'm a freelance
writer have concerns about the abc test
other implications for independent
contractors
i've not looked at it i've not looked at
it
jd straight shot says some people are
saying megan kept inviting the queen to
her 4th of july bbq
turns out the royal family doesn't
celebrate the fourth yeah that'll
that'll do it that'll be a problem
very strong uh issue for sure um big
thank you to nug wrangler for
gifting a subscription as well as amber
bamberwamber
tommy r well dirty curta
uh thanks to the four of you for signing
up via twitch putting us at 28
and from the standpoint of website
memberships let's see if i have anybody
to welcome
uh i don't oh that's sad that said
i would love it i would love it if you
uh grabbed a subscription on my website
joinedpacman.com and i will thank you
profusely i will say good things about
you that probably aren't even true
if you grab a membership on my website
ryan says i know you're hesitant about
political debates for sport but would it
be funny to see crystal ball debate
kaylee magnani
yeah sure ferret queen says where do you
think we in southern new england will be
in late june in regards to covid i'm
getting married and don't want it to be
a disaster
i i don't know i i have no predictions
uh i think the us will be doing better
as far as regionalization
i don't know um it's too soon to tell
too soon to tell okay oh speaking of
kaylee let's just look at a clip she's
been appearing on fox news now that
she's a fox news employee
i guess she delivered a completely
weaponized bit of disinformation
last night let's listen in her role as a
fox news analyst former white house
press secretary
kaley mcinerney kelly kaley great to see
you welcome aboard good to join you
martha
great to hear with us um so there's a
bunch of things actually that i want to
ask you
about that in terms of the the press
availability
um here's what jen sachi had to say when
she was pressed on that today you know
what that feels like in there here she
is yes
will we see more of president by end
specifically more than 40 q a's in the
last month or
more submitted to more extensive
questions
follow-ups the kind of things we're
doing today um we'll will
we see him regularly i don't know that
you'll see him more than 40 times a
month but i'll have to tell
i'm happy to ask him that question oh i
love that i mean this is such a change
kaylee uh
from what the press is used to um he
does not make a lot of appearances when
he does it's those really quick in and
outs
um from the room what did you think of
her answer there
yeah you know i don't think it's a good
answer and i actually warned some of the
reporters there in the press corps in
the waning days of the trump
administration he didn't do as much
press availability as he did
uh every day when he was walking to the
helicopter those press conferences and i
said to the
the correspondents you're getting a
little taste how was walking to the
helicopter where you can barely hear
anything and taking two questions count
as a press conference in this world
first of what this will be like in the
biden administration essentially saying
i wouldn't expect to see much of him
um we haven't we're waiting on that solo
press conference we're still waiting on
the date apparently
it's by the end of the month but i think
reporters got used to accessibility
transparency
regular jousting back and forth with the
president and they miss it quite a bit
yeah you know it's also curious to me
that they sent this
delegation to the border including uh
mayorkas
um the homeland security chief and they
you know then
they want they're gonna check it all out
they wouldn't say where they were going
that
no cameras went with them you know maybe
they wanted to get a look at it all
sort of absent of that environment in
the beginning i think it's interesting
that peter just reported that he the
president hasn't looked at their
findings yet it's now three o'clock in
the afternoon on monday
what um does that seem odd to you
it seems incredibly odd uh but perhaps
we shouldn't be so surprised because of
course they refuse to acknowledge
there's even
a crisis uh and i think the first step
to barely anything has changed at the
border
from trump to biden and that's a problem
like more should have changed and the
idea that
we were doing perfectly at the border on
january 19th
and there was a crisis on january 21st
is very stupid but it's all they have
fixing of problems acknowledging that
problem and we know in 2014
when the numbers were not as bad as they
are now in terms of apprehensions biden
called it a crisis then so did obama so
did pelosi
interestingly in 2019 they called it a
crisis
on president trump's watch when the
numbers weren't as bad what we are
seeing is an astonishing 700
increase of kids going from cbp to hhs
this is extraordinary
and if he won't even call it a crisis i
guess i'm not too surprised he hasn't
even reviewed
the findings of his team it's weird
because the things that were being
called the crisis under trump were what
was going on with the caging of kids
that's not what they believed the it's
all backwards it's it's it's
um i guess they assume everybody who's
watching is stupid or ignorant which may
actually be true
and maybe on that basis that's a
commentary that that sort of makes sense
very very strange stuff so that's what's
going on there
um free says what are your thoughts on
universal basic income i
have many videos about that i am
generally for it although i'm also open
to the idea of a negative
income tax you can find my videos about
that
daraten says if you can't hear a
turboprop engine is it really a news
conference that's a great yeah
it's arguably it's not there needs to be
some kind of uh
aircraft making it hard to hear the
president for it to really be
a press conference in the in the old
fashioned style
thank you to astrolycos for gifting
10 subs on twitch also thanks to
technicolored
flurries and shellburger
that's 13 13 plus 28
3 plus 8 is 13 11
42 square root i believe that puts us at
41.
also thanks to small fuzzy moss who just
subscribed with the message i'm fully
vaccinated as of last thursday my
anxiety levels have dropped considerably
yeah me too me too and the new cdc
guidance from yesterday which i actually
have
here is um is is good
where are the full recommendations let
me see here
um oh this isn't the one with the list
okay in any case um vaccinated people
can gather indoors in small groups
without precautions
but you still got to behave in public
spaces you can
visit unvaccinated healthy people if you
are vaccinated as long as they are at
low risk
agency still does not recommend travel
for any american vaccinated or not
um etc etc okay yeah so we we have a
full
we have a big story today on the on the
podcast and broadcast show about that i
am glad to see those
new guidelines i think they make sense i
think they'll encourage people to want
to get vaccinated
and that is important i want to say a
huge thank you to sarah newman
sarah just signed up at joinpackman.com
sarah newman oh apparently got a second
membership
at and a third one sarah i don't know if
you meant to get three memberships
we're going to count all three uh at
least for the time being
and uh thank you very much sarah taking
advantage of the coupon code
better 21 today which we love
we love it okay i have some new callers
first of all before we go any further as
many of you know we are now beyond the
troy york phone calls they've become
shallow and pedantic but here is a
voicemail
saying end troy york listen to this
people feeling very strongly about it
so i popped into your stream today and
um
look mate this uh troy york nonsense
needs to stop it's just sad it's
pathetic
um i i i know i'm a joke man i know he's
like a troll
um and you know i do i do like a good
troll but
god he's [ __ ] boring so please enough
with the uh
enough of the troll york yeah i mean
listen it's like how often can you
repeat them and i'm an israeli
venezuelan argentinian communist
until it's sort of like okay we get it
you don't know anything and you you
watch
very strange shows i've never heard of
so yeah we're we're beyond the troy york
okay i have three voicemails from the
manic moderate
and then a new voicemail from someone i
think we're going to call
young puts would you do you guys want to
hear the manic moderate first
or young puts guy what do people think
unclear
young putts guy let's go with young
putts guy okay this is a new caller new
caller alert
you are a young
putt that needs
to i i welcome anything that has young
attached to it
be uh out of our country
i mean we need rid i am a citizen i
don't know where you'd send me
our country of people like you you're
such a does that mean jews what is he
saying people like you
nimrod i mean you have no idea
in your brain what's really happening
and destroying our country
you are you're a putts
you're you have no idea i'm listening
this crap
on your show that uh
i mean are all my callers drunk
sometimes i wonder you want
fighting you know fighting
you go ahead have all the fun with biden
okay destroying our country and you're
gonna be a part of it
it's like what's he just he's been in
six weeks nothing's changed other than
we're vaccinating more people and we
passed stimulus
okay so that's young putts nimrod guy
um and then uh what
else oh manic moderate okay so manic
moderate
left three voicemails let's take a
listen
ah this is bob from lakeland florida i'm
sorry i don't agree with you about
what happened to dr seuss the free
market
did not dictate it wouldn't be sold no
more
because that is there are some of the
most popular books on the planet
i mean i've most of the books that they
decided to stop printing i'd never even
heard of
dr seuss those were like to me they were
less known books i don't know
adam my family's all had them
my grandparents i mean come on
wait a second uh hold on is this
starting
oh no it's not we just have we do have
live video okay let's continue that
is [ __ ] now
you're going too far right that's not
true free market didn't dictate it
a bunch of little smealy mouth little
crybabies
dictated it and they came to the
pressure
of a few minority little cry babies who
want to nitpick about some of the
pictures in the book
all right so that's manic moderate
voicemail one i'm not going to play all
of it he called back
again wow this is bob from lakeland
florida
you know nutty bob that's what a lot of
people call me nutty bob
there's buddy bob over there yeah
and nutty bob whose daddy was in the
military
nutty bob whose daddy was in
world war ii and and actually
buried a lot of those bodies that people
want to deny about all that holocaust
deniers
well my daddy had to honor what one of
them
to take a big bulldozer because all
those bodies were so
deep deep i don't know what bob's
talking about and then one more
voicemail from the manic moderate
yeah bob down the floor oh crazy bob man
i mean tell you used to be on cb channel
19
talking all good truck drivers you know
you know what's a shame though
is all this hate i mean not but hate
all right there it is let's listen to
jen saki
uh joining us today is bharat rama murti
the deputy director of the national
economic council for financial reform
and consumer protection
brought was formerly the managing
director of the corporate power program
at the roosevelt institute
he also served on the congressional
oversight commission for the cares act a
position he was appointed to by senate
majority leader chuck schumer
last year previously brought was the top
economic adviser to
senator elizabeth warren during her 2020
presidential campaign
and senior council for banking and
economic policy in her senate office
right he will give you some brief
deliver some brief remarks take a few
questions
and thank you so much for joining us
thanks jersey sauce and privy for the
subs by the way
good afternoon earlier today the
president had the chance to visit a
couple of small businesses here in town
uh one is a locally owned hardware store
that's been around for 150 years
love hardware weather which lease is
part of the same space as an urban farm
that was founded just eight years ago
like other small businesses across the
country these companies help serve their
communities
the hardware store sponsors little
league teams and holds events with the
cub scouts
the urban farm serves hundreds of local
households and supplies food
for local farmers markets unfortunately
a lot of companies like
this with fewer than 20 employees were
left out of previous rounds of small
business relief
too many mom and pop businesses and too
many minority-owned businesses were left
behind
while larger well-connected businesses
got funds quickly
the president and the vice president
have made it a top priority to ensure
that this round of small business relief
is distributed more equitably
and that the companies that may not have
gotten relief before have a real shot at
getting relief now
so today we want to share some early
results of how this administration is
already making good
on that commitment on monday february
22nd the president announced important
changes to the paycheck protection
program
which is the primary small business
relief program that the federal
government offers
these changes were intended to ensure
that mom and pop businesses
minority-owned businesses
businesses in rural areas and other
underserved categories of businesses got
the help that they needed
these changes included instituting a
14-day period
starting on wednesday february 24th
during which only businesses with fewer
than 20 employees could apply
for relief the idea behind the
exclusivity period was to give lenders
time to focus on reaching out to smaller
businesses
including businesses that may not have
that they may not have worked with
before
and to make sure that these smaller mom
and pop shops had their had time to get
their applications in
and improved and at the same time as the
president's announcement the
administration launched
a whole of government effort to let
small business owners and lenders know
about this opportunity
the small business administration
launched a series of conversations
reaching thousands of community leaders
through webinars every day white house
officials held
calls with that ended up reaching
thousands of small business owners
directly
and the administration partnered with
congress to help members spread the word
about the changes
and conduct outreach with their
constituents so now we're
reaching the end of the two-week
exclusivity period and the results are
pretty striking
when comparing the data from the
exclusivity period with the 10 days
preceding the exclusivity period
we've seen a significant increase in the
number of loans to the smallest firms
to minority-owned and women-owned firms
and to first-time ppp participants
specifically we have approved more than
three hundred thousand loans for
businesses
with fewer than five employees that's a
fifteen percent increase compared to the
pre-exclusivity period
we've approved nearly two hundred
thousand loans to first-time ppp
borrowers which represents a 25
increase there has been a 20 increase in
loans
to minority-owned businesses and that
translates to an additional 1 000
minority-owned businesses accessing
relief
relief every single day of the
exclusivity period there's been a 14
increase in loans approved to
women-owned businesses which translates
to an additional 600 women-owned
businesses accessing relief every day
and there's been a 12 increase in loans
approved to businesses in rural areas
but that's not all on february 22nd the
president also announced several other
changes to expand access to ppp
and as of last friday the sba had
implemented all of these changes
and we're already starting to see some
early momentum from those changes as
well
for example nearly 30 000 loan
applications had previously been flagged
because the small business owners were
delinquent on their federal student
loans
we removed that restriction and can now
advance those applications
wow and tens of thousands of new
applications have already come in after
we increase the amount of relief
available to sole proprietors
and the self-employed so i want to take
this opportunity to
say to the small business owners out
there there's still plenty of time left
in this program
there's still plenty of money available
to you go to sba.gov
contact your lenders and see if you can
i should grab some cash right i heard
that there are there are uh people in my
uh
you know industry who who did a little
bit of a cash grab the small businesses
i'm kidding by the way we depend on
memberships maybe that's stupid
more than 50 billion in additional aid
for small businesses
it provides more than 28 billion dollars
in grants to support the
hard-hit small restaurants through the
restaurant revitalization fund
which was a bipartisan proposal in
congress it provides 15 billion dollars
in grants to help the smallest most
severely affected
businesses especially those that serve
lower income areas by the way i don't
even know what's that funny like we have
under 20 employees
and i am latino so like i'm not i'm not
even kidding about that but
which leverages private dollars to
provide working capital to small
businesses
and it creates a community navigator
program so that small business owners
can get help figuring out
how to actually get the relief that
they're entitled to even if they don't
have
a team of lawyers and accountants on
call so with that i'm happy to take some
questions
good this is related to something that
we're seeing
on the hill and there is um sort of an
increasing
movement among senate democrats um to
get
extended unemployment insurance and uh
stimulus checks added to the next uh
built back better legislation
as you're aware senator durbin has
signed on to it uh and
and they argue that this is needed to
sort of keep both of these things are
needed to keep people out of poverty
i'm wondering if you agree with that
assertion from an economic
uh standpoint and and and what your
thoughts are
well number one the american rescue plan
has been documented by
by several independent experts as
providing a tremendous amount of relief
all by itself to lower income and middle
class families
between the economic impact payments the
checks
the changes to the child tax credit
this is there's going to be an enormous
infusion of relief for
for lower income and middle-income
families
as you know and as the president has
said this is only step one
step two is the build back better agenda
and i think we're still trying to
think through what the aspects of that
program are gonna be we actually we've
received the letter
from the senators who talked about
potentially including recurring relief
payments in it we're looking at the idea
but we're still thinking through the
contours of what's going to be in that
next package
thank you thank you so um earlier today
at the events uh president biden said
that a lot of ppp money went to people
who shouldn't have got it i was hoping
you could
elaborate on that and also i was
wondering if you had any thoughts on
concerns about inflation with the new
stimulus bill that's about to be cast
sure so on on the president's statements
i believe he was referring to the fact
that in the previous round of ppp
and the previous administration there
was documented problems
from the inspector general of the small
business administration that tens of
thousands of companies that were not
eligible
for ppp ended up receiving it in part
that was because the previous
administration did not put any
checks in place on the front end in
other words by the way this inflation
question it's like the u.s has had very
well controlled inflation very low
inflation
we did the 2008 obama tarp stimulus once
stimulus
inflation's very much under control and
they keep going and going and going with
this idea
and any second now the next stimulus
will cause
prices to double 100 of applications
within 48 hours so we've tried to find
the right balance between
making sure that folks who are not
eligible don't get don't get the relief
but the folks who are eligible get it as
quickly as possible and we think that's
a significant change from the previous
administration
um on inflation it's something that as
the president has said as
secretary ellen has said we are
monitoring carefully
you know our belief has been from the
beginning that the risk of doing too
little
to help american families outweigh the
risk of doing too much
that said we will always be carefully
monitoring inflation
and and we will continue to do so going
forward thank you given the president on
the verge of signing
the relief till we're seeing vaccines
rolling out a defender
could you give us just a broad sense of
where you think we will be with the
economy at the end of this year
secretary ellen has addressed
employment for 2022 but what about the
forecast for right now
end of the year so moody's which is an
independent wall street firm projected
that
the american rescue plan would bring
back roughly 7 million additional jobs
by the end of the year
uh you know we we think that that's a
pretty reasonable forecast
there are um as we said there's a
significant amount of relief that is
going out
um to lower income middle-income
families through this bill
as you said the vaccine rollout is
accelerating
obviously that in many ways is the key
to accelerating the economic recovery
um so we're optimistic about that and
and there's good uh
uh credible independent experts that
suggest that we will be
making a big big step towards getting
these 10 million jobs that were short
back by the end of the year
low interest rates have made it possible
to finance many of these initiatives
how much debt is too much
sorry i said obama's stimulus in 2008 it
was 2009.
not in terms of necessarily the sheer
amount of debt but
what are the payments that you have to
make on the debt and then that that's
why the interest rates are relevant to
this
we are in an extended period of
historically low interest rates and
not to get too wonky but there are some
structural factors that would suggest
that
uh interest rates are going to remain
permanently
or or there's pressure keeping them down
over the long term
we are carefully monitoring this the
president has made clear
that being fiscally responsible is a
priority of his
he's also made clear that right now one
of the best things that we can do
is uh is deficit finance these
investments because that's what
gets the economy moving more quickly and
in the long term growth helps bring down
the debt and deficit levels as well okay
lesson to bloomberg i promise he'll come
back
we probably let him go soon thank you uh
as
the administration considers what
elements are going into the buildback
better plan
some economists have written the white
house to asset a path to citizenship for
some undocumented immigrants including
essential workers be included in that so
can you describe the white house's
current thinking on whether to include
that provision in the plan
um yeah that is a priority of the
presidents i think we have not made a
decision yet on whether to include or
not include that
honestly in the short term we are
focused on trying to get the american
rescue plan into law
and then going out and telling the
american people what was in the american
rescue plan and how it's helping them
uh you know we will continue to work on
um
putting together the next step of this
the recovery part of this that the
president has previewed
but we're not quite there yet thank you
so much
thank you thanks everyone thanks to
taisha bess
and kevin pruitt for signing up on my
website appreciate you guys thanks
okay um
as the president said last week once the
rescue plan is signed
we'll be able to start getting payments
out this month
treasury and irs are working tirelessly
to make that happen
the irs and bureau of the fiscal service
are building on lessons learned from
previous rounds
to increase the number of households
that will get electronic payments
which are substantially faster than
checks and a number of you and obviously
the american people have asked a lot of
good questions about how this process
worked so we thought we'd try to answer
some of them uh for households who've
already filed their tax
their income tax return for 2020 the irs
will use that information to determine
eligibility and size of payments for
households that haven't yet filed for
2020
the irs will review records from 2019
to determine eligibility and the size of
payment
that includes those who use the
non-filer non-filer portal
for previous rounds of payments which is
a question i think somebody asked
sort of about yesterday for tax returns
with direct deposit or bank account
information
the irs will be able to send money
electronically and for those households
for which treasury cannot determine a
bank account
paper checks or debit cards will be sent
of course we're
not taking anything for granted we're
we're pushing through the finish line
here but
uh you all have asked some really good
questions about the implementation that
we wanted to get ahead of
so here's what this all means for a
typical family of four with parents
making
under 150 000 a year combined and with
kids in school age eight and five
uh because of the president's rescue
plan that family of four will soon be
getting fifty six hundred dollars in
direct
payments and because of the expanded
child tax credit they'll get
twenty six hundred dollars in addition
to that so that's eighty two hundred
dollars more in the pockets of this
family as they travel
on top of additional money in this bill
to reopen schools safely get shots in
arms and help those who've lost their
jobs
through no fault of their own another
scheduling announcement for all of you
on friday morning president biden will
meet virtually
with his counterparts in the quad prime
minister
suga of japan prime minister modi of
india and prime minister
morrison of australia formed in the
aftermath of the 2004 tsunami
and finalized in 2007 the quad has met
regularly at the working and foreign
minister level
however friday will be the first time
that the quad is meeting at the leader
level
the president biden has made this one of
his earliest multilateral engagements
speaks to the importance
we place on close cooperation with our
allies and partners in the indo-pacific
a range of issues of course will be
discussed we expect to be discussed i
should say
facing the global community from the
threat of krovid to economic cooperation
and of course
the to the climate crisis uh
earlier today final piece here our covid
coordinator jeff zions
had a weekly governor uh call with
governors uh from across the country
supply will again increase to 15.8
million doses going out to states
tribes and territories along with 2.7
million
first doses going to pharmacies he also
highlighted the progress we've made as a
nation on vaccinations
on january 20th there was a seven day
average
of 890 000 shots per day today we're
averaging 2.17 million shots per day
so it's obviously a significant numbers
check out finally of course reiterated
our commitment to
working collaborating with governors
from both parties and continued and
encouraged continued focus on masking
social distancing while our vaccination
program continues to ramp
up why don't you kick us off thanks um
question on um with the influx of um
young people and just migrants in
general to the southern border
is there any sense and i asked this
question with the
obviously you're only two months into
the administration but
early on you and uh secretary mayorkus
very much stressed humanity uh and
trying to move away from the
the last administration do you does the
message need to be tweaked at all
do you need to say that it's not just
about humanity
but also you might not get in or you
probably aren't going to be able to stay
well humanity will always be a value
from the president
on down but you are right that we are
continuing to work to convey
to people in the region that this is not
the time to come
that the majority of people who come to
the border will be turned away which is
factually accurate and what we're really
talking about in terms of
uh the people who are being let in are
unaccompanied children
that is a policy decision which we made
because we felt it was the most humane
approach
to addressing whatever very difficult
circumstances in the region
and that means there are more children
kids under the age of 18 of course
coming across the border
at this point is this a crisis at the
border look i don't think we need to sit
here and put new
labels on what we have already conveyed
is challenging this game of
perpetually critic fox news criticizes
they're not calling it a crisis
and then reporters ask is it or isn't it
a crisis and then if they say no then
they say well you're wrong and if they
say yes they say oh so you were wrong
before or you were lying
come on guys that can help address what
we're seeing and help
ensure that we are keeping these kids
safe and moving them as quickly
as possible from border patrol
facilities to
to shelters where they can have access
to educational resources
health resources mental health resources
legal aid etc
go ahead follow up on it thanks um there
are reports out there that the number of
unaccompanied migrants detained at the
border has tripled in the last two weeks
to 3200
plus is that number accurate i'm not
going to confirm numbers from here
obviously the department of homeland
security and others are oversee the
programs and the engagements that happen
at the border
i will say that there are a couple of
reasons i know um are asked about
our kind of change in policy but there
are a couple of reasons
why we think people are coming to the
border of course
individuals are fleeing countries where
individuals and families are
you know they're fleeing prosecution
fleeing violence fleeing economic
hardships and other things
the region has also experienced two
hurricanes in the fall
putting further stress on the conditions
in these countries and the circumstances
that are facing individuals and all this
is taking place during a global pandemic
that has impacted other countries
economies placing undue hardships on its
people just as it did
in the united states so there are also a
range of factors that are leading
individuals to come to the border
why won't you confirm that number that's
a very important number
i i i we've been very clear that there
is an increase
that there are more children coming
across the border than we have
facilities for at this point in time
those numbers are tracked by the
department of homeland security so i'm
certainly i'm just suggesting that you
talk to them about specifics
they won't confirm the numbers well i
would encourage you to go back to them
and ask them again we're not going to
confirm them from the white house it's
not our program it's the department of
homeland security department is the
white house encouraging the department
to release those numbers
and in the spirit of transparency that
the secretary promised here at this
point we certainly encourage
transparency but what i also think is
important is to talk about what the root
cause is i think it's a fair
you either have to say the numbers
should be released or explain why they
shouldn't be released but kind of
playing coy and saying we're transparent
but we won't confirm and they might not
but we can't force them
to see the president travel to perhaps
after he signs this bill
uh to highlight the benefits after the
american
rescue plan is signed uh we certainly uh
recognize that
we can't just uh sign a bill again we're
not taking anything for granted we're
getting across the finish line but
that we will need to do some work and
use our best voices including the
president the vice president and others
to
communicate to the american people the
benefits of this package how they can
benefit from the package
how they can have access to checks part
of the reason i wanted to do that
at the top how it will help schools
reopen and so
i think you can certainly expect the
president to be doing some travel and
we'll have more details on that in the
coming days absolutely go ahead
you talked about the need of getting
these uh 3 000 or so potentially
children out of the
border patrol facilities and into hhs
facilities that are meant to house
children
how quickly can that be done and what is
being done right now to make sure it
happens sure let me
walk you through a little bit of what
the considerations are and what our team
is working on
now so um first um
the reason why these kids are being let
in i've talked about that a bit but
the majority of people come to the
border are still turned away or expelled
under title 42. so
families adults etc we're talking about
children i'm just level setting here
when children are apprehended at the
border they are initially processed as
you've noted
through customs and border patrol
facilities where they are held until
they can be sent to hhs shelters
where the children have access to
education services medical and mental
health services we've talked about this
a little bit but just to reiterate
the reason why one of the challenges
we've had is that covet 19
the pandemic had initially severely
limited the amount of children
that could be taken into hhs facilities
and the pace at which that could happen
so one of our focuses is on working on
seeing how we can address that that
includes looking at additional
facilities
it includes there were some cdc
guidelines that was
that were released on friday and those
guidelines for hhs facilities will allow
capacities to be returned to pre-covered
numbers
all while taking other steps like
increased ventilation
additional masking and other member
measures to continue to keep these
children
safe so one of the things we're doing is
implementing working to implement
these recommendations so that we can
ensure there are more kids who can be
safely
in these facilities we are also as i
noted uh working to expedite
we're looking at additional facilities
where we can safely
house children and ensure they have
access to all of the resources that i
noted
and finally we're also looking for ways
that we can expedite
the way that we vet and process families
and sponsor host families
where these kids can go because of
course once they go from cbp facilities
which we are working to expedite that
we don't want them to be in these cbp
facilities we want them to be in
shelters as quickly as possible and then
ultimately we want them to be in
families and
homes where their applications can be
can be processed but we are looking to
expedite the way that we
um consider the way that we vet families
and sponsor homes as well and last week
you weren't ready to confirm
that new facilities might be brought
online including perhaps
fort lee and virginia or homestead
florida can you give us
any new details about how many new
facilities might be repurposed and how
quickly
it's a good question i don't have
anything to confirm for you in terms of
new facilities we are looking at
facilities
a lot of considerations underway and
certainly part of the reason is where we
want to have more
kids able to transfer from cbp
facilities
to hhs facilities so the cdc guidelines
helped us ensure there are more kids
able to have safely in a lot of these
facilities but
also we're looking at facilities but no
decisions have been made at this point
can you tell us anything about any
diplomatic efforts that are taking place
between the biden administration and the
central american countries
to find ways to deter some of these
children from coming that's a good
question that's a great question and
it's a key part of our strategy
i've actually asked roberta jacobson if
she could come join us in the briefing
room so we hope to do that
uh sooner rather than later because
those are great questions that i think
she would be an excellent person to
address
but in the meantime no information about
any conversations that are taking place
between the u.s and the
sure well all i was conveying is a
commitment to get you
an even an expert that can that is
involved in these discussions who can
help answer your questions but
uh and i also conveyed that it is a key
priority for us and that there are
conversations going on
at a number of levels obviously through
our national security team through the
state department
about the importance of conveying
clearly this is not the time to come
working with countries on how we can
address the root causes as
as you know but everyone may not know
one of the key proposals in the
president's immigration bill
is additional funding to address the
root causes and that's something we're
certainly communicating about so
but i think what i heard from you is
specific questions about engagements a
lot of those would be read out from the
state department but
i've invited roberta to come and we'll
look forward to having her here soon
go ahead thanks so airlines have been
urging
the administration to develop guidelines
for a travel passport
so americans can begin traveling the
country again
is that something the administration is
considering doing
it's kind of weird because you can
travel the country already kind of
guidelines
vaccine passports i believe they are
calling it right
well we recognize that as many americans
get vaccinated
questions will come up and they're
already starting to come up as to how
people will be able to demonstrate they
are vaccinated i think it's important to
remember only about 10
of the american population is vaccinated
at this point
we've obviously made progress but we
have more work to do and right now
our our focus as the us government is on
getting
more people vaccinated and we'll think
about how people can demonstrate
they are vaccinated as we get more
people vaccinated but that's where we're
putting our energy and resources toward
we also know that the private sector as
as you noted in your question is
is concerned and has raised this and uh
and we believe they and not-for-profits
will be
uh driving this initiative and all
likelihood moving forward
so it sounds like the administration
doesn't want to get involved in setting
the standards for what would qualify
someone for a vaccine passport
well being vaccinated the vaccine
passport is something that's been
designated by
the or an idea coming from the airlines
what i'm conveying is
there are lots of ideas that will come
from the private sector and nonprofits
we we welcome those but our focus from
the federal government
is on getting more people vaccinated and
that's where we feel we can use our
resources best
another subject uh there's a report
today on the south china morning post
that
the u.s and china are trying to set up
some sort of high-level diplomatic
meeting
in alaska to try and reset relations is
that any kind of meeting like that
under is that being planned or is that
under consideration
right now i have heard or seen those
those reports
um i don't have anything to report out
to you obviously the president spoke
with president xi
ju back february 10th and we will look
forward to
seeking opportunities for engagement but
we don't have any details uh
finalized or confirmed at this point
lastly is there any
uh further updates on the website
you can ask them not the website okay
you can you can i was ready i'll save
that one for next one okay
uh but on on for possibly next week is
the president uh
chosen a date yet or working with
congress on a joint address to congress
and what's that gonna look like as far
as being virtual or in person
uh i don't have any update on that for
you and certainly as soon as we have a
date confirmed we are looking forward to
doing a joint address we're working
please do it before we go on vacation i
hope
on uh the address the president will be
delivering on thursday night during his
first prime time address he'll talk
about covid
that'll be covering the country and what
the path forward looks like and we'll
focus on
the next address once we get through
that go ahead
thanks phoenix for the 20 subs gifted on
twitch i appreciate that
just getting them you've you and the
president have both said that they're
going to be going out this month but the
last round they went out pretty quickly
i think within a few days so do you know
any more specific timing on when people
should expect them
it's something our treasury team is
working on and and working to expedite
of course and that's a priority to the
president
one of the steps they're taking is
working to ensure more people can get
them electronically because that of
course speeds it up
so let me actually just give you because
i have a little bit more detail here
caitlyn in terms of how it will work
so the first batch of payments will go
to all taxpayers who provided direct
deposit in their 2019
or 2020 returns followed by taxpayers
who didn't provide that information but
for whom the irs has
payment information from other programs
and of course as the president said once
the bill is passed we'll be able to
start getting these payments out this
month but in terms of more specifics
we're
waiting for them to get all their
systems in place and then we'll hope to
have an update
and any update on whether or not he
wants his signature on there like former
president trump demanded
well we are we are doing everything in
our power huge funds write the payments
and not delay them which is why the
president's name
will not appear on the memo line wow
this round of stimulus checks uh the
checks will be signed by a career
official at the bureau of fiscal
service this is not about him this is
about that's great people getting relief
i love that 160 million of them so did
he did not want his name to appear on
the checks
he didn't think that was a priority or a
necessary step his focus was on getting
them out as quickly as possible
beautiful okay thank you and on
immigration
uh you said you've wanted to stay away
from labels i know the
the dhs secretary has not wanted to call
it a crisis but instead referred to as a
challenge
but right now since it is 3 200
unaccompanied migrant children according
to documents from monday that's higher
than the peak of the 2019 border crisis
when it was around 2600 then
and at that period there were kids
sleeping on floors they were overcrowded
facilities
so when his delegation traveled there
did they see that people sleeping on
floors and
overcrowded facilities well first one of
the reasons is because there we have a
different policy than the last
administration we're not turning kids
away at the border
unaccompanied children we're also of
course not ripping them from the arms of
their parents
and so we know and we that we knew we
know there is going to be an increased
number of kids coming across the border
there are several steps as we've talked
about a little bit that we're working
to address that uh the team of course uh
we put out a readout of their
meeting they are going to do a meeting
of course and and give the president a
full rundown
of uh what they saw on the ground a trip
they that he asked them to take and i'll
let them do that before we
uh have more specifics and we of course
are committed to ensuring there's
transparency and
access uh for cameras to the facility as
well so do we have a timeline on that on
when reporters will actually be able to
go
in and see because that was kind of that
was what was so helpful last time yeah
showing people what it looked like
inside there so
is that going to happen within the next
week or is it going to be
pushed further down the road than that
when can cameras actually get inside
those facilities we're committed to
doing that i don't have a timeline
for you at this point in time we want to
do it uh with respect
for the privacy of the people staying
there uh people who are
being housed there but also uh abiding
by covet protocols and so we're working
through some
of those steps okay my last question is
did president biden agree that the
travel restrictions should not be
changed for people who are fully
vaccinated like the cdc
the cdc guidelines that was a
determination made by
the cdc it wasn't a uh driven by or
directed by the white house
and as uh as uh rochelle dr wolenski has
said it's just a first step
and as more people are vaccinated
they'll look at ways to ease
additional restrictions but there were
some reasons as she outlined that
travel was not a part of this according
to what the health and medical experts
who are working at the cdc determined
which includes uh the impact of travel
you know ten percent of the population
is
is vaccinated ninety percent is not it
still remains of course uh
it still is a concerning a concern
there's still concerning impact of
travel
on people who are not vaccinated and
also because we are still tracking and
looking at the impact of variance
so they will look at all these factors
uh this again was just a first step on
guidelines as she has said and
i'm sure they'll look at a range of
factors as they've committed to as more
people
in the country are vaccinated go ahead
thanks jen couple questions
um to follow up on the border why has
this administration been so reluctant to
call it a crisis
here we go uptick in the number of
migrants being detained including
thousands of children
if that doesn't qualify as a crisis what
does well because we think that it's
most important to explain the
substantive policy of what's happening
uh what the root causes are of why these
kids are coming
and why what we're doing why do you guys
think they keep asking about that is it
because they
they want a shot at getting some kind of
gotcha
type situation like why why do they keep
asking that i don't
i don't even get it what happened with
the president's dogs or some reports
that
one of them was involved in a fighting
incident can you clarify exactly
what happened sure uh champion major
the president and first lady's dogs uh
members of the family
are still getting acclimated and
accustomed to their new surroundings and
new people and on monday the first
family's younger dog
major was surprised by an unfamiliar
person
and reacted in a way that resulted in a
minor injury to the individual
which was handled by the white house
medical unit with no further treatment
needed
it had been previously planned already
for the dogs to be cared for by family
friends in delaware during dr biden's
travels
to military bases this week she has a
three-day trip this week
and the dogs will return to the white
house soon
go ahead sabrina i'm thinking of the
curb episode where
the dog is at first racist and later
homophobic
support for infrastructure legislation
does president biden
support the return of earmarks and are
there specific restrictions that you
would seek to prevent the kind of abuse
that has occurred in the past sure well
we don't have an infrastructure bill yet
don't even know that it will be an
infrastructure bill and in terms of what
it will look like and what the
negotiations will require we are
happy to have that conversation when
it's uh when it's appropriate but right
now we're focused on the american rescue
plan so
we're not going to get ahead of the
legislative strategy for a future bill
position on earmarks more broadly i
don't think anything has changed about
his position he obviously was in
congress for
36 years but in terms of what it will
look like or what
restrictions would be on a new package
i'm sure he'll hear from and we'll eager
to listen to
members of both parties and about their
views on this issue and
we'll certainly factor it in as we put
together a new uh his next step in the
buildback better agenda
in the second question the indian
government has threatened to jail
employees at facebook and twitter
if they do not comply with the
government's data requests or requests
that they take down
accounts associated with these farmers
protests that have been ongoing
for months now what is the
administration's view of a foreign
government threatening to jail employees
at u.s companies right well certainly we
believe in freedom of speech freedom of
press
freedom of expression and it is a
concern uh that
the president and others at the highest
level raise at every opportunity
uh even with allies with adversaries uh
and uh but in terms of specific
conversations about this i
expect the state department would be
closest to those engagements
go ahead karen some questions on the cdc
guidelines yesterday it's obviously
very big news for families yes but the
message that we heard from officials was
all about families and you didn't hear
anything about school reopening tied to
these guidelines
if vaccinated grandparents can be with
their unvaccinated children
without masks how do you apply that same
standard
to schools well these guidelines where i
don't want to get over my skis here as a
non
i am not a doctor yeah you really can't
because it's for people from a
one household in schools you have people
from a bunch of households
for people's homes right so karen you
and your husband and your kids
can you know engage with and have dinner
with your neighbors when everybody's
vaccinated
that is certainly a positive step
forward for many many many americans
these were not guidelines for a
workplace whether it is the white house
or a business or a school there were
guidelines provided of course for
schools and i think the cdc is sees it
as imperative
that they take different circumstances
with different um
looking at the the very specific uh
engagements the number of people the
risks as they factor in
what guidelines they're going to put
forward when can we see guidelines as
more people get vaccinated
than applied to schools or applied to
workplaces or with these same standards
well uh they will continue to review how
would she know that i said
as more people are vaccinated uh there's
a greater opportunity to
make recommendations that will allow
people to spend time together
to hug grandparents cousins teachers
and certainly that's all of our hope but
uh they look at all the factors
including the impact of variance as
she's talked as she talked about when
she rolled this out
and uh and and make recommendations
based on how to keep the public safe
and you know there is a concern that has
been raised by all of our medical
experts about not
taking our foot off the gas here we are
we are close relatively so given the
last year we've been through
and they put out these guidelines
because they feel comfortable that
uh you know about the data they have as
it relates to vaccinated individuals
but of course they need to continue to
analyze data
look at health and medical advice talk
to the doctors at the cdc
before they make additional
recommendations vaccinated how will he
change his behavior based on these
guidelines will he see grandkids more
will he see family in a different way
than he was doing
before these guidelines came out you
know of course the president abides by
the
cdc guidelines as no one would it would
be expected to hear um
but he also believes he needs to be a
model for the american people and all
citizens i haven't this is a great
question i haven't talked to him about
how it will impact him
personally in that way i'm happy to
venture to do that or all of you could
ask him next time you have the
opportunity uh but i
noted that and this was a good question
uh someone asked i think
over the last 24 hours about how it
impacts us
here and you know the white house is a
place of work right it is not
a private home and so we will continue
to wear masks we will continue to be
tested we will continue to
socially distance until our health and
medical experts uh tell us otherwise
go ahead in the back thank you jen so
two follow-up follow-ups and
then a couple of questions first the
follow-ups um about the quad
uh virtual meeting um can we see this as
a
as a prelude to re-engaging
uh the t the tpp
i wouldn't see it as a direct connection
to that no this is an opportunity to
engage at a engage at a newbie
engage at a high level at an even higher
level than has been done in the past
with key partners
uh to the united states uh japan
australia
they're they're key partners uh to the
united and india sorry
they're key partners to the united
states there's a range of issues to
to discuss and work together on whether
it's addressing the climate crisis
whether it's
working together to address the global
pandemic or of course economic
cooperation but
i wouldn't see it through those prism
the president has been clear about
his commitment to rebuilding the middle
class and looking at any
engagement trade engagement through that
prism um okay thank you
as for jordan's story uh question about
the uh
the south china morning post eventual
discussion
and anchorage i have a uh my colleague
from
kyoto news the japanese news agency is
asking
how will they biden more broadly how how
will the
biden administration plan to engage with
the chinese are direct talks
under consideration direct talks with
the chinese well i mean the president
has spoken with president xi
already so of course we remain engaged
directly through at a range of levels uh
and that will continue
like a summit type of event i'm not here
to predict a summit uh
of course there'll be a range of
engagements that the president and his
national security ability
team will have with china and other
countries in the region in the
months and years ahead but we are
directly engaged
there are a range of issues we of course
have talked with the chinese
about through those engagements we don't
hold back about our concerns but we also
look for opportunities to work together
jen just a week
actually eight days precisely before
the the president entered the white
house the previous administration
um and put cuba
back on the list of state sponsors of
terrorism
does the president share this via
uh well we've talked about this um a
little bit in here before
and nothing's really changed but i'm
happy to reiterate our policy
our policy as it relates to cuba will be
governed by two principles first support
for democracy and human rights
will be at the core of our efforts
through empowering the cuban people to
determine their own futures
uh second americans especially cuban
americans are the best ambassadors for
freedom
and prosperity in cuba a cuba policy
shift is not
currently among president biden's top
priorities
but we are committed to making human
rights a core pillar of our u.s
policy and we're committed to carefully
reviewing policy decisions made in the
prior administration including
the decision to designate cuba as a
state sponsor of terrorism
very very last question go ahead it's
about the border
okay you keep repeating this is not the
time to come
will there be a it is not sending the
signal that there will be a time to come
just wait
well first to be clear even these
unaccompanied children who come across
the border group we've talked about we
want to keep safe we want to ensure they
are
in shelters where there is access to
educational services legal services
health services
we want to ensure that they are then
quickly moved to vetted families or
sponsor homes
many of them don't stay because they go
through the process of having their
applications
reviewed we just want to keep them safe
because they are kids under the age of
18.
and when we say it's not the time to
come now the reason is this is a we are
these questions exposed that the
immigration situation
is a mess but it's not more of a mess
now than under trump it's just that
under trump the rhetoric was totally
different and you weren't actually
getting substantive answers
to some people it seems like wow now
it's a mess and before it wasn't no
she's just admitting how much of a mess
it is
which means investing in smart security
which means creating a pathway to
citizenship which means
funding and supporting efforts to
address the root causes
in the region and we as a part of that
we want to ensure that there is
effective processing at the border
we're not trying to close our borders we
are trying to keep create an
effective moral humane system it's going
to take some time to do that
go ahead thank you jen i'd like to ask
about three things if that's okay the
the dogs immigration and then governor
another dogs the dogs okay
go ahead just a quick clarification on
the dogs can you confirm that it was a
secret service member who was bitten and
can you also reassure the public that
major biden will not be euthanized as a
result of this
well certainly major biden is a member
of the family oh my god
i don't have any more details on the
individual um i would encourage you to
ask the secret service but i'm not going
to have any more
details other than that then on
immigration
you've said repeatedly now is not the
time to come but you've also
noted there's a distinction for
unaccompanied minors that they're all
being allowed in
um i want to revisit something the
secretary mayorka said last week he said
that uh
loving parents end quote uh we're
sending nine-year-old children alone
um of course there are people showing up
and saying who's major biden major biden
is a dog
people are like i can see people who
think it's a person they're like who bit
someone
so i was hoping to drill down on the
messaging there uh do you think it's
important to send the message
to children unaccompanied children that
now is not the time to come
and to their parents that it's not a
quote loving act
to send them i think it's imperative
that we send the message that this is a
dangerous journey
children don't make it they experience
very difficult circumstances on the
journey
now the circumstances in a lot of these
countries is such that the parents feel
that
taking that risk is better than the
circumstances they're living through
but we are very clear about this message
in the region uh that this is not the
time to come
that this is a dangerous journey uh that
we of course are focused on modernizing
our immigration system
uh and and making it a system that can
better process
uh people at the border make it more
humane we are going to abide by our laws
and continue to
uh implement those laws but i can assure
you that message is being sent clearly
in the region so now is not the time to
come for children as well jen are you
willing to definitively say that champ
is a good boy
uh you've been asked this uh many times
about his uh the sexual
harassment allegations against him i
just wanted to confirm that you have
spoken with both president biden and
vice president harris about the
allegations
yes and i've reiterated on their behalf
that
they believe all women should be heard
that they should be treated with respect
they there's an independent
investigation as all of you know
that is being led by the attorney
general who named i believe some
individual lawyers will be in charge of
that today if i'm if i'm reading reports
correctly
uh and certainly they respect that and
believe that should move forward
speaking um
themselves about this these uh
allegations i don't have anything to
predict for you on that front i'm here
to speak on their behalf so that's what
i venture to do on a daily basis
go ahead jen is it true major biden
prefers cat food instead of those dry
pellets
we were promised a white house cat what
what happened to that where is the cat
today's a good day for the cat
um i don't have any update on the cat we
know the cat will break the internet
but i don't have any update on its
status
has the president now ruled out
nominating sherlander young for omb
director is she is she deputy for keeps
would joe biden consider
a white house alpaca where are we on
that
well nero only pulled herself out of
consideration
six days ago if i'm doing my math seven
days ago
sorry if i'm doing my math correctly
here the president is committed to her
serving in a role
in the administration because he values
her perspective and her experience
in terms of shalonda young no we are we
have not made it the president has not
made a decision about who he will
nominate
he thinks so highly of her that he
nominated her to serve as deputy
director of omb which is an enormous job
uh
in the administration and once she's
confirmed she will
will you deny joe biden wants to hunt
wild boar on the white house lawn
on the timeline or decision making for
uh the nominee
and uh people in the running for some of
the ambassadorships have been told that
bob
iger has got the gig in london are you
able to make an
announcement today well they would be
incorrect given the president hasn't
made any decisions about any
ambassadorial roles
go ahead uh i'm climate john kerry is on
his first
overseas trip in brussels right now what
is president biden hoping he's going to
accomplish
there well the president asked
for secretary of state my former boss to
serve in this role because he knows
about his
he's very familiar with his personal
commitment to addressing the climate
crisis not just domestically but of
course internationally which is the role
that former secretary kerry is playing
this is an opportunity for him to
engage directly now that we've
officially regained rejoined the paris
climate agreement to have discussions
with
counterparts with officials that the
former secretary knows well from his
experience as secretary of state and
working on these issues for many decades
and
i'm sure that he will be reporting back
to the president uh when he returns
and carrie mentioned in his remarks that
he wants to raise the ambition of the
initial
paris agreement please um how much more
ambitious than that agreement is the
administration
willing to go and is there really a lot
for when you guys are going to
announce the 2030 emissions targets
that's a great question i think we'll
wait for the secretary to return from
his trip and i'm sure he'll have a
conversation with
of course both gina mccarthy the
president the vice president and others
about what his recommendations are and
what there's an appetite for out there
in the global community
but i don't have any predictions uh for
you at this point in time
great go ahead in the back hey joe cleo
with news nation yes hi
first time here right welcome i'm a
newbie as well
good there you go thank you i'm the uh
american rescue plan
there are two far-reaching measures i
think the child tax credit which you've
mentioned
and the affordable care act subsidies
that are both
now temporary measures there are some
calls on the hill to make them more
permanent
is president biden interested in working
with congress to make them more
great questions you should please um
address some of the criticism that those
two mentors specifically have been
getting
that they are not in any way related to
covered relief or stimulus directly
well i would say if you're a family with
kids
then the notion that the child tax
credit is unrelated to the economy is an
absurd notion
so i don't know who the critics are but
i i would be surprised if they had small
children
i would say the president had talked
about making the child tax credit
permanent during the campaign
he certainly is open to continuing to
look for
avenues to do exactly that he believes
that benefits like the three thousand
dollar child tax credit that is
included in this package are benefits
that help address
what he and the vice president feel is a
crisis which is the
large number of women who are leaving
the workforce um and have left the
workforce since the pandemic
uh started so he will certainly continue
to look for avenues on that what was the
other piece i'm sorry you asked about
the other one
uh the affordable care act oh of course
look i think one of the things the
president is committed to
has talked about talked about on the
campaign i should say when he ran was
strengthening access to affordable and
accessible health care so one of the
things we did was we
uh reopened the period of time where
people could apply
to uh on the uh to get to get access to
uh the benefits from the affordable care
act we've seen a huge um
a huge influx of people who were not
previously covered
with health insurance do that and he
will certainly continue to look for ways
to
reduce the cost of health insurance to
look for ways to expand it to make it
more accessible
and certainly having lived all lives
through a pandemic
the need for greater access to
affordable health care is is pretty
front and center for him and others in
the administration
sabrina sure go ahead and has spoken
often about the need for a two-step
rescue and recovery approach to the
economy he's held many meetings on
infrastructure and said the recovery
plan would focus on infrastructure
manufacturing other issues
were you saying that you're not sure
there's going to be an infrastructure
bill
when i asked about your marks well that
no decision has been made yet internally
about
look the president has not made a secret
about what he what is in his buildback
better agenda he talked about it on the
campaign trail infrastructure is a part
of that and it's something he's had a
long commitment to
he's also had a long commitment to
investing in caregiving to doing
investing in our manufacturing sector to
doing something about our tax system
so there are a lot of components of his
buildback better agenda what i'm
conveying is
we're still in a policy process
internally about
what uh the next part of his agenda will
look like
and what the format the size the order
will look like so that's all i was
conveying but certainly infrastructure
is one of the areas where
he feels there's opportunity for
bipartisan support and for democrats and
republicans to work together
go ahead i can follow up on that too the
president made overtures to republicans
when it came to covet relief inviting
many of them to the white house
and at this point you have zero
republicans in the house or senate
voting
for this package is there going to be a
similar
effort to try to get republicans on
board if the next
agenda item is an infrastructure how
much does biden have to do for
obstructionists
structured to date as he's looking to
gather ideas and hear from democrats and
republicans about
how they feel we can continue to work
together and rebuild
the economy i would say that well
we don't expect or did not receive i
should say to date republican votes for
the american rescue plan uh the
individual the republicans in
d.c are and living in the zip code or
seem to be outliers
in the country given the majority of
people in the country the majority of
republicans
right support this package so maybe it's
some
a moment of self reflection but it's the
point to keep hammering on
republican opposition to the bill
doesn't reflect republican voters
feelings
i know it's early days but is the white
house committed to
getting bipartisan support for an
infrastructure package or
would you rule out this that was just
the question that was asked
reconciliation like you guys did the the
last guy asked this am i stupid the last
guy asked the same question to work
together in a bipartisan manner that's
part of why he's had
two bipartisan meetings on
infrastructure weren't both questions
are will they try to get support from
republicans for infrastructure
and his agenda and certainly we're not
going to take uh that off the table in
terms of uh paths forward uh that's
in a fantasy world uh go ahead
uh is there enough money to deal with
the surge of kids at the border and has
there been any discussions
of invoking emergency emergency
exploration
you mean in terms of opening additional
facilities
uh it's a good question i i'm happy to
talk to our immigration team and see if
that's part of the
structural issue it may as i understand
it part of the issue is finding
appropriate facilities in determining
what process steps can be taken
to expedite the processing but i'm happy
to talk to them about that
and get an answer back to you go ahead
the structure build package
there was a bipartisan push last year to
knock down the pavement of the top paid
federal employee
the ceo of the tennessee valley
authority who reportedly earned
15 million dollars last year in
compensation
there are democrats in congress who
support this the former president
supported this some conservatives do
uh it does divide an administration
believe that an infrastructure bill
should
slash this 15 million dollar
compensation for a country i appreciate
the opportunity the president believes
everyone should pay their fair share but
we don't have a bill that actually
exists so we're not going to talk about
what components would be
a part of it or not at this point in
time go ahead well at the risk of asking
you what
is one of the components in this
hypothetical bill
a question from someone who can't be
here today andrew feinberg
president biden has repeatedly spoken of
both the need to upgrade the nation oh
andrew follows me on twitter i think
his desire for the us to become a leader
in zero emission
vehicles so since the federal highway
trust fund is funded by taxes on gas and
diesel fuel which obviously
wouldn't be collected from zero emission
vehicles does that mean the president
will insist
that any infrastructure bill will
include a new funding source for it come
on
i just am not going to get ahead of a
bill that has not been designed
formalized finally throw away packaged
terms of size scope or timeline
at this point in time
okay thank you everyone have a great
afternoon so there's jen
saki answering some questions multiple
times getting many questions which are
hypotheticals about what would joe
biden's position be on a bill that
doesn't yet exist
all right i mean you know some good
questions let me
get to everybody's super chats i don't
want to miss any i do want to say thanks
to jordan ross
jordan just got a perfect membership on
my website
joinpackman.com thank you jordan
also want to say thanks to some twitch
subscribers including
auntie euleka k shreds
k fish k rolex a lot of k
stuff going on ryan uh
zachary flea girl that's seven
artie the party gabber is eight
um okay eight
very good i think i'm staying on top of
all of this stuff
uh okay and then super chats and then
we'll just keep an eye on this jury
selection in the derrick chavin trial
though it looks like they're in a recess
right now
chris says when do you think we'll see
our first politician or official speak
live and perform
american sign language or have we
already i don't know that we've
well first politician yeah we probably
have already seen that
uh i don't know enough about it coraline
says alpacas for the white house
daraten says will joe euthanize the dog
named for his dead son yeah the
euthanization question was weird
the term migrant crisis was an important
term to politicize people in europe in
2015 i think they're trying to invoke
that level of imagery i think you're
right
um nathan says saki said accepting
people fleeing prosecution i think she
meant persecution the usa shouldn't be
housing foreign fugitives right
i believe that she misspoke yeah
jody says ginger sends 10 bucks with no
question thanks ginger
jody says please don't play the moderate
whatever guy again i don't want to hear
about bulldozers f that guy
john says candace owens might run in
2024
and it scares me do you think
republicans will play the race card
against democrats please god don't let
it happen
yeah i think it would be hilarious for
candace owens to run
but republican primary voters are dumb
enough to vote trump so they might be
dumb enough to vote for candace owens
that's the scary
part of it dereten says dr
seuss literature for the conservative
movement
greg says yeah all these people who
don't read are outraged that six
dr seuss books will no longer be
published it is very funny
greg says nutty bob indeed and um
oh technically i did not mean to order
more than one subscription but i
am happy to keep them thank you very
much
very much appreciate that hi
david donato here so refreshing to hear
a press secretary
not bring up the previous administration
every question yeah she only brings it
up in some questions
when relevant which i think is
relatively
reasonable i will be streaming
thursday night joe biden's prime time
address
on coronavirus i don't know what he
might say
we know cases have been declining deaths
have been declining vaccinations surging
cdc loosening some guidelines for
vaccinated individuals
i don't know what he is going to say but
i will be covering that live
in prime time on thursday night so
i hope to see everybody then from the
standpoint of
raids let's raid
kit boga hopefully kit boga is not on a
repeat today
so if you're watching on twitch follow
me over to raidingkit boga
and i will otherwise see everybody
tomorrow